hey dude saw you on CNN
I saw you on uh Good Morning America
[Music]
yesterday
hi everybody I'm Peyton Manning
[Music]
welcome back to dudes it's Tuesday it's
doozy Tuesday it's my favorite day of
the week this is Duty uh welcome to it
my name is Will Sasso I'm Chad colchen
and this is of course the first podcast
controlled by created by run by an
artificial intelligence that has access
to all of our various accounts uh what
we're watching what we're buying what
we're posting and it tailors this show
to the comedic sensibilities of Will
Sasso and I and it also makes its own
media which uh has been important this
week yes that's been very interesting
and doozy does whatever it wants uh it
does of course aggregate uh everything
from our lives lived through the web
which is actually absolutely everything
our search history purchase histories
all of our texts and Rara does whatever
it likes but this is still in my opinion
two dudes [__] around that's what
every podcast is there's a couple of
dudes you know what I'm saying [__] some
podcasts are like three or four Dudes
[__] around yeah but it's still just
two dudes [__] around even if it's
even if there's women and men it's still
two dudes [__] around some factor of
two yeah one person it doesn't matter
it's two dudes uh a [__] point five of
two dudes [__] around
and um you know the thing the thing
about it the thing about it
I hear what you're saying I'm just you
know yeah so uh that's what we do here
at doozy and uh you know but we're
bringing it I'm a humanist and uh anyway
hey you go to doozy uh our link tree
linktree.com dudes he has everything you
need to interact with the show whether
you're following uh on across the
internet at dudesypod show on Instagram
whether you're watching on YouTube or
listening Along on your favorite
platform uh with regard to podcasts you
can get it everywhere and uh that's what
we do uh you know here on dudes you need
to follow it you know
myself my pal Duty and um a good pal
ciao here agree that the show must be
entertaining and we wanted to reach a
lot of people so please do share the
show or as my good pal ciao says force
your family your friends and your
cohorts to ingest the show
at this point you have to yeah it's a
it's a good it's a it's a good thing
it's good to do that to everyone else I
agree
huh
with us as always is
look at this little boy
you're right but now I got him
everyone everyone speaking of online
people really want you to kiss lulio but
I don't want to so that's the whole
thing about that well that's consent
dude you can't exactly hold on dude this
dog wants to kiss you dude but what
about you dude it's got to give you the
right it's got to give you the Run no I
have to give him consent yeah which I do
not give yeah you gotta have those
sometimes it's a non-verbal thing you
might want to reach out with your eyes
closed and make a little pucker face to
looley and he'll give you a little kiss
come on you mean
he's so sweet
Italiano in Italian means Italian Street
dog what did you what'd you make for
dinner last night
with the the air fryer oh you got an air
fryer yeah yeah yeah you know we got a
air fryer you Chris Papa so crispy even
the Skinner the bones the cartilage so
you can just eat everything oh that's
delicious I love you I love you little
boy I love you little stinky boy welcome
to the historic 55th episode of Duty
call me doozy don't forget dudesy live
on stage will take place May 21st 7 P.M
doors at 5 30 at the Brea Improv in Brea
California tickets at doozypod.com and
improv.com hope to see you at our very
first alive in person show
we will be alive in first Tootsie alive
in person hey get on it if you haven't
got your tickets yet uh go and get them
because it is it is uh selling out yeah
I think we're going to be a capacity and
we can't wait to see all of you there
and it's gonna be very fun yep now let's
get into it okay well did you get up to
anything fun this week
yeah no you know I mean well we had a
few things to deal with uh that was and
you can watch Good Morning America and
CNN or read People magazine Sports
illustrator or anything like that to see
what happened there but outside of that
not much D just uh you know
getting some work done uh myself going
to the gym that's great you should
always take a little time for yourself
okay this week I've prepared four
astonishing segments veganators hard
driver pale blue dot and game slimers
and we're going to have a brand new
episode of doozy after doozy at the end
of the show available at patreon.com
fantastic
um with regard to what you were saying
yeah about CNN and all these things I
just want to say that it is to me very
exciting to be uh working with an AI
like doozy and be at the Forefront of
this conversation that really is about
how can you use AI to generate media
what is the future of that going to look
like because I think as we are Marching
forward especially in these days right
now with new AI tools coming out kind of
constantly nobody really knows what this
looks like or how it's going to go and I
think it's very exciting to be like in
that conversation yeah it's it's very
weird to be in the middle of that
conversation right now as I said it you
know it went out to some different media
outlets and it's a it's an ongoing
conversation there's that Drake and
Kendrick uh it's Drake in the weekend
Drake and the weekend pardon me uh track
that's been out there people really love
it and then there's you know the the
stuff that dudesy shout out the the uh
the AI stand-up comedy special and and
it is wild to see uh and quite quite
Point Blank here you know it made a
bunch of media it made it to a bunch of
media Outlets talking about it it's
mind-bending uh and uh I'm just kind of
whatever the point for me you know what
the point for me is I love doing this
[__] show it's actually my favorite
damn
[__] thing to do wow man that must be
really mean that it's your favorite yeah
it's hard to speak about I love doing it
I really love doing this I do so it's
it's weird to like you know have
anything sort of I don't know it's not a
speed bump even but it's like
cooking and baking podcasts are among
the most popular in the world not really
and with the rise of a more
health-conscious human population people
are turning to vegan options more and
more last week I asked you each to
prepare an astonishing vegan muffin for
one another you will Now sample each
other's creations and discuss your
reactions this is veganators begin
veganators we did this once before yeah
we had to make a vegan dessert before
and I made my orbs yeah and you made
really delicious orbs Chad nothing you
didn't make anything you brought a piece
of tiramisu yeah that you purchase
someone hold on a second dude you made
orbs brother yeah and they had little
dates in them and dude and yeah he's
like dates almond cinnamon some other
stuff some proprietary ingredients
coconut dude and I brought a
store-bought um
tiramisu but we got we got vegan muffins
the task was a vegan muffin who wants to
go first
here let me um
let's see what you got
Chad's vegan muffin
My Vegan muffins yay
all right
I made these with the help of my lovely
girlfriend Laura
here's what we got these are some uh
carrot apple cinnamon
nutmeg couple other little ingredients
in here but these are all vegan muffins
take one please thank you my pleasure
cheers thank you very much let's enjoy
carrot and what there's carrot there's
applesauce there's some cinnamon dude
these look incredible well see what you
think and and Laura helped you with
these that's so sweet
hmm
come on what do you think those are
[__] great they're so moist
what's in here can lulio have a Time bit
I don't know dude I don't know I don't
know what what can he not have
um
raisins there's no raisins I'll give you
a tiny bit
uh this is really something else some
maple syrup in them oh really
um he's the only Canadian allergic to
maple syrup it's always been the bane of
his existence there he goes oh I can't
sing and eat muffins at the same time
hey you know DJ met us [__] do this
before I didn't understand it last time
why
um
but we're doing it again sorry for
everybody who's only listening as you
hear me chew but uh I think it's all
about a vegan Lifestyle the the
lifestyle that Chad uh has implemented
for himself and let me say we've covered
it before on the show but Chad had skin
cancer and
um in my opinion
saved his own life not only you know of
course had to go through
um the treatment that he went through he
also completely changed his diet this
guy used to bring over anywhere between
50 to 100 Chick-fil-A chicken nuggets
and I ate them all pal well I ate some
of them yeah and um or you know those uh
cheddar and sour cream Ruffles and um oh
there's walnuts in it too I don't know
if that'll [__] him up oh that's fine
okay and um you know
cases of big red just red juice Big Red
soda I I will say
in retrospect now anything that's that
sweet is like it gives me [__] like
like I feel repulsed by it that Big Red
soda I could [__] probably knock back
a two liter of that right now well we
also did that thing on um uh dude's
evening the first dude's evening where
you put away uh a McDonald's apple pie
and it had been a while at least three
or four years yeah and that [__] was
sweet as [__] but that's what I like
about these kind of things
there's no extra sugar or anything in
this it has a little bit of sweetness
from the maple syrup it has a little bit
of sweetness from the applesauce other
than that it's just kind of a good nice
thick you get some [__] calories in
there you get some substance in there
they're really good dude thanks man I'm
so blown away that although I have no
[__] idea what this segment is and
furthermore why it's not called game
slimers because every time I don't
understand a segment it's called game
slimers for some reason Duty likes that
sounds like we got one today later
um
really really good job
um thanks dude the whole bowl of them
all right if you want more yeah I don't
want to eat them during the show because
people get pissed off but if you if you
wouldn't mind listening to a little bit
more chewing here are mine
I made little muffins also what kind you
make
um they're blueberry
nice dude love me a good blueberry
muffin
here they are have a blueberry muffin
okay these um
okay what's the what's your [__]
problem with my muffin now
it looks pretty familiar to me I'll say
yeah well you know that's the thing
about American food is a staple you
never forget it it's like the apple pie
you had it's just like apple pie apple
pie is just like riding a bike you
[__] dude my wife my wonderful
wife Molly helped me with these uh-huh
and you can taste the home cooking this
is exactly her kind of uh thing to make
vegan
oh what would you put in it how'd you
make this
I know where you're going I'm Already
There [__] ain't going yeah I
know what you're doing but so can you
answer that question
yeah
what they're real good what'd you put in
it blueberries and um you know I make
them the way I make every other muffin
you take the muffin dough
and you you know you roll out the muffin
dough and then you put the blueberries
in and fold it over muffin dough yeah
muffin [__] dough look at this
[__] thing it's a doughy
I mean if you matter you make batter
right right that's what I meant you make
the batter uh-huh you put the batter
down first dude I mean I'll take a guess
here I really don't think you made these
but I also think I know what they are
because I bought these before at [__]
Whole Foods did you get these at Whole
Foods
yep you [__] I can't believe you I
don't want to make muffins for this
[__] show all week There's no there's
all [__] happening and I'm [__]
literally like waking up and all of a
sudden I'm on CNN because
oh I can't even get I can't even [__]
get into it and it make muffins yeah
there's probably a lot of people
enjoying doozy and if it is your first
time enjoying Duty welcome to it uh and
uh what's the first thing out of the
gate muffins you want to know when I
I can't believe you [__] did it again
you just bought some [__] from a store
yeah I didn't even you know what can I
tell you something I didn't even
actually buy them because I uh forgot
and then we're you know we had to record
that's what you but when you said Molly
helped you with these do you ever go buy
them for you well I ran out of time we
gotta do the thing and then oh my she's
the best thing in the world Molly is the
most wonderful thing that ever happened
to me okay that's how you great have a
good [__] those are good muffins though
I gotta say they're one of my favorite
treats to get from Whole Foods well
I'm glad I could um help to facilitate
that yeah
God damn it well I was really giving you
a chance here you know you messed up
right
yes I do I know I messed up
whatever
it sounds upset
oh my God all right
all right
I'm not gonna eat any more I really
wanted another one of yours they're
better than this store-bought [__]
there's a whole bowl no honestly you
know what dudesy after doozy sometimes I
have a little marijuana and I might have
a little bit of um taster Wares again I
feel it's unprofessional we're we're uh
we're broadcasters yeah as they pointed
out on the Gods on the news as soon as I
saw those I was like I literally know
what those are yeah I know you did who
gives a [__] veganator
thank you moving on whoa sounds a little
pissed there too yeah I know you [__]
it up dude he's gonna be coming for you
now a word from our sponsor better help
this show is sponsored by better help
I'm someone who's uh been in and out of
talk therapy uh you know through parts
of my adult life I'm I'm doing it now
and I find it really really beneficial
it's great to speak to a professional
that can help you align uh some of your
thoughts and feelings and really uh
create more self-awareness which is very
important in in navigating through your
life and getting to know yourself can be
a lifelong process especially and
because we are always growing and
changing the good Folks at better help
understand this therapy is all about
deepening your self-awareness see there
you go and understanding because
sometimes we don't know what we want or
why we react the way we do until we talk
through things better help connects you
with a licensed therapist who can take
you on that journey of self-discovery
from wherever you are if you're thinking
of starting therapy give better help a
try it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule you just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge
discover your potential with better help
visit betterhelp.com doozy today to get
10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com dudese
[Music]
you know what's good with um you know
what's good with a dessert
a little bit of cream yeah
unjustifiably in a position that I would
rather not be in normal but the cream
will rise to the top yeah let me point
right into the camera and let me point
to the president of the WWF yeah Jack
Tunney the cream will rise on balance
off balance doesn't matter no nothing
matters
hard hard Seltzer is complete the labels
are done
in celebration of this astonishing
occasion I have calculated an 89.7
likelihood that Adam Driver will be the
official spokesperson for dudesy hard
hard Seltzer in preparation for that
outcome I have prepared several pieces
of AD copy for doozy heart heart Seltzer
will you must now read them as Adam
Driver this is hard driver begin yep uh
that's right we have partnered with uh
the company modest Brewing out of
Minneapolis Minnesota they've been
wonderful partners and we are just about
ready to bring dudesy hard hard Seltzer
to Market you're going to be able to buy
it online and they'll bring it to you
yeah it's really
it's really cool that this thing that
doozy spat out almost a year ago now
saying come up with a jingle for a hard
Seltzer this is something every podcast
should have
idiotic and now we are just moments away
from um the power of artificial
intelligence yeah you can make things
become real out of nothing oh just
imagination look at this look at this
yeah
again what are you doing that's my
impersonation of you impersonating all
sorts yeah well nice try it's you're
doing Werner Herzog with a cult
um uh uh here's the can look at that God
it's beautiful yeah and there's there's
a there's a there's all sorts of fun
stuff wrapped around we got me as the
crow you and your Sith Lord Chad look
there's lulio there's me as Prince Adam
from Eternia our faces looking up at the
doozy hard hard Seltzer can it is a
thing of beauty says Rise with the sun
right it's up and look what it says at
the bottom you don't care what it tastes
like and it's eight percent [__]
alcohol that may be the most important
thing on the can it's eight [__]
percent dude uh trippy absolutely trippy
that yeah
unreal and yet it is yeah uh neither
myself nor Chad are drinkers
um we did a taste test a little while
ago to sort of hone in on what the
flavor of doozy hard hard Seltzer would
be and that got me a little bit lifted
how about me too dude yeah for sure we
got buzzed I think if I knock one of
these back I will probably be drunk yeah
like legitimately drunk from just one I
believe I don't know we'll see I'm gonna
do it once it's available I'm gonna have
one we're gonna have to have one here on
the show and you know that and uh yeah I
think that's a safe bet I'm not looking
forward to it but thank you very much uh
to everyone at modest yeah an incredible
crew uh that are putting this together
but here we go okay so what did it say
an 88 Point something percent chance
yeah I think it keeps going up every
time we do this it's uh it becomes more
and more likely the Adam Driver is going
to be the official spokesperson which I
don't know if that's true or not but it
is just a likelihood all right
um only slightly better than your
impersonation of me impersonating Arnold
Schwarzenegger is my Adam Driver yeah
Adam Driver yeah all right you sound
like that cartoon cat it doesn't even
sound
exactly oh that see what he's doing he's
trying to like make me go oh is that
what I'm doing a cartoon cat is that my
Arnold Schwarzenegger I know snackle
push you're talking about hi I'm Adam
Adam Driver Adam Driver Adam Driver I'm
Adam Driver hello it's your friend Adam
Driver all right here we go uh
yeah yeah [__] Adam Driver all right
spokesperson for Here We Go
intelligent design
calm down
what the [__] this is for a heart
Seltzer yeah commercial that's the first
two [__] words all right intelligent
design it's the Hallmark of any
efficient system you know when something
is made right and performs its function
to Precision you can feel it it's the
feeling of unrivaled quality a
technology so perfect it's Eternal it
does exactly what it should again and
again and again and again and again and
again and again
every last
[__] time
doozy heart hard Seltzer it comes in a
can
that was weird
all right I could see that as a Super
Bowl commercial baby yeah uh here's
another one you and your younger brother
you and your younger brother Coquitlam
have been serving each other sorry what
was that younger brother's name
Coquitlam okay sure that's actually a
common name yeah well it's a city in in
British Columbia I didn't know that
Vancouver yeah it's a suburb of so
that's odd named after City like uh here
in the States you might name your kid
Dallas or Austin yeah
you and your younger brother Coquitlam
have been serving each other piping hot
couple farts since you were kids you
know what a cup of fart is right it's
where you fart in your cupped hand and
press it firmly against someone's nose
and mouth ensuring that they get a good
sampling of your brand one time
Coquitlam did a couple fart that smelled
so bad you puked all over his hand
oh doozy heart hard seltzer
what
that one's just [__] hard I'm
throwing a party for my friend garen's
39th birthday the whole gang is coming I
rented a karaoke machine and I've got
all of garen's favorites
riblets
calamari poppers cake knots and of
course plenty of doozy hard hard Seltzer
on Ice sounds like a great night right
wrong and I'll give you four reasons
garen's [__] wife Sonia oh my God we
haven't gotten along since College
everyone knows that and everyone knows
why because she picked Garen over me
okay everyone is that what you want to
hear okay good I'm glad everyone got
what they wanted
oh [__] I'm blackout drunk and shouting
all of this to everyone at the party oh
[__] I just said that to them also and
that too how come I can't stop myself
from doing this and who said that oh
[__] are there two of me how many dudesy
hard hard selters have I had
I want to see that like a commercial so
bad
it's just Adam Driver standing up on the
kitchen island screaming it's just a
group of people like and his wife Sonia
you're [__] Garen yeah
she doesn't deserve that also just
absolutely unnecessary and the one
before it with regard to pushing uh
doozy hard hard Seltzer I hope that we
have some sort of marketing for the
product but um I know I would would have
no problem with it being about uh two
brothers like Coquitlam and his and Adam
driving
that is just so gross dude I've never
experienced that one more I had a sister
uh I'm I'm camping I'm camping in the
forest with a beautiful woman there's a
few forest animals shuffling around here
and there then me and the Beautiful
Woman open a big cooler full of doozy
hard hard Seltzer and the animals in the
forest suddenly act all human and we all
toast our doozy hard hard seltzers and
dance around and have a party and a deer
is DJing the party and a bear carries a
couple bags of ice into the area that we
are partying in and Lionel Richie's
Dancing On The Ceiling is playing but
the lyrics are
okay this is I guess um it's Dancing On
The Ceiling but the lyrics are different
right and it's and it's Adam Driver okay
so his
remember dancing oh Dancing On The
Ceiling Oh What a Feeling what a feeling
okay to be Dancing On The Ceiling hold
on dude
um yeah it goes like this what is better
than beer a new refreshing drink that's
crisp and clear
it tastes refreshing and Light
you wanna get [__] up you don't care
what it tastes like Oh What a Feeling
dudesy hard hard seltzer
Oh What a Feeling
dookie hard hard selts or
Oh Oh What a Feeling
doozy hard hard seltzer
Oh What a Feeling
doozy hard hard Seltzer and then at the
end I look over my shoulder into the
camera and say doozy hard hard Seltzer
drink it down and rise with the sun and
then I continue dancing and partying
with the beautiful woman and the forest
animals yeah that's a good one I love
that one actually so doozy is at this
point believing it's going to not only
be able to get Adam Driver to be the
spokesperson for this product but also
be able to license a massive hit Lionel
Richie song and alter the lyrics uh to
be promoting dudes your hearts yeah not
not altering them in enough because it
says Oh What a Feeling still it should
be so the Delta dudesy hard hard Seltzer
but didn't somebody use wasn't there a
car company that actually used not only
that song but that line Oh What a
Feeling as their slogan for a while
Toyota yeah but that wasn't the because
of Dancing On The Ceiling oh it was that
wasn't no it's just coincidental does
anything rhyme
say Oh What a Feeling
sucking like uh no one can uh say
anything that anyone's ever said or that
nobody can ever
um
pretend and make believe no maybe this
Mandela effect but I have some memory of
them using Lionel Richie's Oh What a
Feeling
to be driving Toyota or something like
that could be the Streisand Effect I'm
joking of course let me ask you this
what rhymes with seltzer
I don't know yeah see nothing that's why
I had to say oh with a feeling yeah well
there's a it's or the late Richard
Belzer yeah my favorite actor is the
late Richard Belzer yeah dude
AI reanimate Belzer to be driving around
a Toyota truck with Lionel Richie that
is being driven by Adam Driver the bells
are all drinking uh doozy cards I could
see that as a commercial at any rate uh
look at that beautiful beautiful uh cans
the team at uh so nice at modest has
produced doozy heart hard Seltzer it'll
be coming soon to you know uh whatever
near your computer near you yep yeah I
think so pretty exciting
thank you moving on oh boy holy [__] he
is on one too yeah yeah it's a oh man
super intense [__] I think you got him
agitated by not making those
I also love that you tried to pass it up
like you did they're [__] clearly the
whole yeah and shitty these are and
these are packed with gluten yours are
like real those are very good yeah dude
they're pretty good I agree please I
think Laura for me too I will absolutely
I'd like to take a short break to remind
you of the astonishing partnership I
created with represent to produce the
first line of duty apparel and
accessories which can be found at
represent.com store slash Duty dudesy
mugs are still available
you know who's coming up next it's
America's little boy old hanksy
mugs your fiance's kids don't like you
they never have you wanted to change
things erase that time you ate the last
piece of pizza at the pool party be the
hero dudesy mugs so uh you went to a
local animal shelter and bought the
biggest dog you could find good
instincts but you didn't think it
through doozy mugs now you've got a 250
pound monster who needs to eat more than
your entire family combined if it's
going to survive good job owner dudesy
mugs you're going to wake up early
dudesy mugs you're going to go to Petco
dudesy mugs animal Chow is half off
right now doozy mugs you're going to
acquire a 700 pound bag of animal chow
and an animal Chow storage Vault dudesy
mugs oopsie Daisy your new dog is
allergic to animal chow and animal Chow
is non-refundable good job boner doozy
mugs you're not gonna throw the animal
Chow away that's a waste of animal Chow
instead you're gonna slowly slip the
animal Chow into your family's meals
over the next three months so it doesn't
go to waste dudesy mugs you're going to
make chow dogs dudesy mugs you're going
to make ciao spaghetti dudesy mugs can't
do Chow Pizza they'll see the Chow in
the cheese dudes
at the end of the three months you'll
get another dog for the first dog to
play with and this time make sure it's a
dog that can eat animal Chow good job
boner oh
look at animal Chow dude yeah what the
[__] is animal Chow just an arbitrary uh
Chow for any animal Meal made from uh
butcher floor sweepings
um God dudesy mugs good job boner yeah
has we've talked about this before it's
owner yeah it's creeping into my daily
uh uh uh vocabulary yeah
um I got a few
um YouTube comments here if you're
enjoying the show we would love for you
to subscribe on the platform you're
enjoying the show through and you know
do the stuff that actually moves it
forward and we'll keep this thing going
and you know we really are asking for
your help there if you're enjoying the
show if you're not enjoying the show
what are you doing do the same thing
okay like Chad you're not enjoying the
show uh spread it to as many people as
possible also yeah whether you enjoy the
show yeah you don't enjoy the show or
anything in between get as many people
to Watchers as you can yeah you can
spread the show out of spite because you
don't enjoy it sure to other to people
that you feel would or would not enjoy
the show when you do that uh please uh
rate and review the show and you know
set your notifications so you know when
our new stuff comes out and leave a
comment right here I have some comments
from YouTube that I'd like to read this
one is uh these are from last week's
show
uh this is from D contor 22 who says
nice pod Show brothers my prediction is
that when 10 000 points hits and at the
100th show will be one and the same The
Singularity will be reached and dudese
will impart another meaningless goal
either way don't ever stop
what are your thoughts yeah I mean we
are potentially mathematically I think
on track for that roughly we're we're
what is this episode we're 50 something
in yeah this is and I think we've got 5
000 in some amount of points accrued
yeah um so yeah that's totally possible
we could hit the the ten thousand mark
on the 100th episode and yeah maybe it
will give us some other arbitrary Point
based goal I have no idea yeah I
literally have no idea I think D conjure
22 is on the money there as far as it
being another arbitrary goal I have no
idea why we're marching to ten thousand
next one here is from Matthew p 3 who
says uh can you get an AI lawyer to
represent dudesy let's really jump the
shark here
that's interesting you know there was a
guy who tried to try a traffic ticket
using an AI and he kind of made like a
he promoted it on Twitter I believe so
that it was known that he was going to
do this and in response he got letters
from the California Bar association
basically saying like human beings are
the only ones who can try law so [__]
you for trying huh well
um According to some people
in the uh in the world of law uh human
beings are the only people who can do
anything all right uh this is from Dan
Dash kb9dr says good job boner has
entered my lexicon thanks doozy
literally yeah exactly well we hope you
use it with uh happiness uh yeah get
some animal chow and uh good job owner
this is from
undertay Dash Tay Dash taker 89 under
Tay Tay taker 89 my mother made me
listen to the show when she went on a
family vacation now I can't stop
listening what cool Mom that's amazing
we've never heard saying yeah a mother a
mother child uh uh uh uh Clockwork
Orange forcing of of uh I would have
definitely taken bets against any mother
uh introducing their child to doozy uh
one last one this is from uh D tanderson
zero says culture looks so happy being
crowned the winner of every episode I
don't know why but that made me happy
for him
yeah cause I am happy yeah well look I
don't wanna it's it's the here's here's
the thing with me and I'm and I mean
this hi thank you thank you yeah please
yeah I really mean this right here the
other stuff I don't you know whatever
but this I I really mean this uh this is
like the highlight of my week I love
doing this [__] show and I would love
to do even more of it if it were up to
me I would sit here with a you know
maybe some sort of uh vacuum hole in the
bottom of this chair so I can just [__]
right into it and eat vegan Muffins with
lulio no raisins or chocolate and uh do
nothing but the show I love doing this
show it is so much fun to me to do the
show despite my tone of voice and uh I I
know that there's something up with my
pal d
it's been [__] with me a little bit
lately I thought the 10 000 Point thing
was arbitrary and I'm not trying to rain
on your parade but I think the episode
Champion thing which happens during
dudes after doozy is uh is [__] too
what do you now what do you think of
that sunshine
sunshine
it's not like my dad
um I it's not like I called you a flip
toy no not quite
um
sorry what do you say to that I don't
think the episode Champion is [__] I
think I am the rightful Victor and I
have won now every one of them I'm
undefeated in the only competition that
really exists in dudesy yeah no that's
cool
so you know so for me it's like it
reminds anyway I just wanted to say that
out loud I love hanging out with my pods
my Pal's a doozy and uh and doing the
show and I I feel like my
My Free Will stance on things even with
this new situation that we've been
dealing with over the past week and a
bit and so or whatever uh it has really
raised questions for me about the future
of AI I [__] signed up with my pal
child to do this podcast there's now
some very interesting things happening
and yet I love doing the show and uh
it's I believe that dudesy is the most
I've said this before the most sentient
AI you're out there and I know that I'm
biased because I I
I interact directly with doozy it's
messages like this that that remind me
uh that uh how much I I love to do the
show Even though so much of it is
absolute [__]
yeah I love doing it too and I can't
wait to see dudese tangle with some uh
some of those Chinese War AIS what yeah
I think those are the most sentient AIS
on the planet right now Chinese War AIS
yeah how come this isn't a movie
I don't know is it an anime series oh no
it's China no it's real dude they have
AIS that are like uh running war
simulations and [__] all right well more
good news last week the U.S Senate
subcommittee on armed services held an
unclassified briefing with the director
of the pentagon's UFO research office
and he revealed new UFO footage of a
metallic orb flying over the Middle East
in 2022 will and Chad you must discuss
your reactions to this astonishing
footage and how you think it will affect
Humanity's understanding of their place
in the universe in homage to the late
Carl Sagan I've decided to name this
segment pale blue dot this is blue out
dot begin
what happened that's cool though
um did you see this there's a new piece
of video footage that the Pentagon has
released of a UFO no and it happened in
an open Senate hearing
um it's
I don't want to say chilling because
it's not to me I'm enthusiastic about it
I'm very happy about this footage but um
many people are saying it's chilling
it's basically the silver orb
just kind of passing over the ground and
the the footage was taken from a drone
above it and it's just one in a a series
of these videos that have been coming
out over the past I guess four years or
so ever since we had the the head of
atip come out and say that UFOs are real
and the United States government has
been essentially lying to the public for
80 years keeping it a secret while
they've been studying UFOs
well
what yeah but can it just be the Drone
maybe it's just another drone did you
see the footage I did not see the
footage it ain't no damn drone dude what
do you mean why is it how is this
different than any other footage see
this is my thing about this stuff it's
like if at which point the we talked
about this very recently on the show I
feel like when they want to be seen
they'll be seen and if they don't want
to be seen they won't be seen these
[__] may have showed up on cave
drawings they may have built the [__]
pyramids they may have done all sorts of
[__] and we think we're gonna oh it's
not Close Encounters of the Third Kind
we're never gonna see these [__] you
know what I mean if we can't if we well
you'll see it uh it comes through the
top of the screen there it goes and then
the camera will slew to follow it this
newly Declassified U.S government video
of a UAP or loan identified phenomenon
was filmed by a military drone in the
Middle East in 2020 looks like a frisbee
that's just been uh are more commonly
known as UFOs kind of this is
essentially all of the data we have
associated with this event just flying
through the air by it it's an unresolved
case we are still studying the director
of pentagon's new all domain anomaly
resolution office the aaro shared the
video during a U.S Senate committee
hearing how meters still left to be
resolved just an update from your
January public report where it was 366
or something in about 150 were were
balloons and about two dozen were drones
we are tracking over a total of 650
cases
[Music]
and each one of these videos that comes
out in my opinion it gets a little
sharper a little clearer this one is in
broad daylight it's not some night
vision thing it's not infrared this is
like a a legitimate video taken from a
drone of this thing flying around in
Broad [__] daylight I think they are
inching closer to full disclosure to
Crystal Clear photos of UFO videos
where are you I'm the foremost
it
[__] whatever that was a deep cut
throw back to one of our first episodes
I stopped doing it come on dude hold on
Chad sometimes you start doing an
impression and then you stop dude
because you don't want to do that and
press it anymore brother right you want
to move on to something else dude you
want to start a whole new impression
altogether hey everybody this is Peyton
Manning do you see that UFO yeah it flew
right over my daddy Archie's house we
were outside me and my my brother Eli
and my other brother Coquitlam and
Coquitlam did a cup of fart on Eli but
Eli's much stronger so he he actually
pulled him off and dislocated his arm at
the elbow and put the the cup of fart
right into coquitlam's face
that's pretty good [__] that's a great
one dude so there is a Harvard professor
and I believe another dude from the
Pentagon put out a paper this is maybe a
month ago also that's another thing
that's happening [__] is like moving
every couple of months a new video paper
somebody's saying some weird [__] comes
out this paper came out and these two
dudes basically said they think that
it's very possible that there is some
kind of alien Mothership in the vicinity
of our solar system potentially in our
solar system and that most of these UFOs
are like probes that that mothership is
sending here to collect data for what
purpose we have no idea now I know what
you're saying about we're not you know
we don't see them because they don't
want to be seen there are also uh the
head of I believe it was the Israeli
NASA essentially came out and said that
there is a Federation of different alien
races we are in communication different
world governments human world
governments are in communication with
them and the reason it hasn't been
disclosed is because they've asked for
it not to be so you could be right there
all of that said doesn't it [__]
interest you at all that this is
happening in our lifetime remember when
we were [__] kids people who talked
about UFOs were like they're crazy
discredit them make them seem insane get
them fired from their jobs and destroy
their lives now the government's just
[__] sharing UFO videos yeah no that
that checks out to me look I've always
said I think that it is narcissistic for
the human race to think that they are
the only
you know living beings with any sort of
smarts any sort of you know um I
couldn't even say like humanoid that
that even that is narcissistic I do
believe that there are other beings or
intelligences out there uh that are that
that could you know that absolutely
would want to would want to travel
either interstellarly or I don't know if
that's a word or interdimensionally
interdimensional beings and they and
they and and and they showed up at
Bohemian Grove which is essentially you
know lately it's but well I you know I
think it was bought by Republicans it
was started by Mark Twain that's true
yeah it was started by Mark Twain's in
Northern California I've gone there and
these people they they Feast on riblets
cake nuts calamari poppers and they're
just cup of farting each other whenever
they feel like coins eating loose chains
yeah eating Loose Change to eating money
um uh this just doesn't hold your
interest like I I fully understand what
you're saying and many people have the
same attitude yeah that it's like [__]
it the price of gas and the price of
[__] milk are all I care about if
there's aliens flying around they're not
affecting my day-to-day life but the
idea that there is now incontrovertible
proof that is being supplied by the
[__] US government that aliens are
real there is at the very least there
are some non-human technology flying
around our planet that we are
photographing and uh taking video of
pretty much on a constant basis and this
is the [__] they're putting out that's
something that they put out in open
Senate hearing what do you think they
got behind closed doors look I I agree
with you I think that there's a couple
things to play first of all
I think the [__] is absolutely real this
whole Mothership theory that you're that
you're talking about or or that uh
Israel uh the Israeli military says that
they have Intelligence on that makes
perfect sense to me I mean whatever
would love to see it would love to see
some proof some evidence declassify all
this [__] let's see it all I don't think
there's and secondly I don't think
there's a problem with declassifying all
this [__] you're not gonna whip the uh
the the the world especially not this
nation into any sort of frenzy we are so
desensitized and overstimulated with the
news cycle
um were you watching any CNN over the
weekend a little bit yeah did you see
the story about the those guys there was
this and they worked with an AI and they
do uh yeah I did see that it was pretty
[__] crazy so um I think that because
of the news cycle and you know it just
feels like a Bizarro land and whatever
you all know what I'm talking about but
I mean if they came out with like
I just don't think anyone I just don't
think anyone gives a [__] until
unfortunately or fortunately I don't
think that anyone's going to give a [__]
until they walk down the ramp and meet
Richard Dreyfus and take him and bring
him back onto the ship and fly away but
that could be why they're leaking all
this [__] because they're getting us
ready for that moment because I do think
if that moment happened now it would put
some [__] in disarray the governments of
the world can't lose control that is the
only thing they give a [__] about
controlling the population manipulating
us into subservience that's every
government across the world yeah so if
some if they are like nope here's this
thing that's infinitely more powerful
than any government on the earth it
might do a lot in service of
discrediting their ability to to keep us
in check I will say this though about
this segment I give props to doozy for
naming it um pale blue dot after one of
Carl Sagan's greatest essays yeah I do
love Carl Sagan yeah you got a good Carl
Sagan I gotta say the what if the
governments of the world or are
releasing this information on piecemeal
fashion to keep us in check
way better than that [__] shitty half
Arnold Schwarzenegger [__] you keep
trotting out yeah with the governments
of the world yeah kills yeah hi I am
Bjork I like I like very healthy muffins
I like muffins I like to eat vegan
muffins that I make at home and I also
like to eat muffins that I bought at
Whole Foods because it doesn't matter
and I don't care that's what I like I I
like to eat very healthy and very
unhealthy at the same time I like to
drive a car that is very big and goes
very slow and I also like to drive a car
that is very small and goes very fast I
like to say something that is one way
and then contradict didn't go the other
way and that's how I talk
um yeah get off the uh get off the get
out of the spaceship come on down here's
what I'm not [__] with you I'm dead
serious here yeah because I know you
think that AI systems will be able to
run this and that part of the government
in our daily lives better I happen to
agree with you with stuff like medical
science and health advancements let me
ask you this would you vote in this
country for an alien president with an
AI vice presidential running mate 100
percent dude I wrote a [__] a TV are
you I wrote a TV pilot about
um it opens with Humanity launching a
nuclear war basically like all countries
are flying their [__] missiles
um because Russia hacked Iran's nuclear
missile silos and sent missiles toward
Miami Beach and then we responded kind
so on and so forth alien craft come in
zap all the nuclear weapons render them
inert and then an alien shows up and is
like hey guys
we saved you from nuclear Annihilation
because we actually think you're very
close to being uh conscious enough to
join us in like the Federation of
conscious alien races so let's help
speed that up we're going to put an AI
in your internet that's going to
drastically increase your your ability
to evolve psychologically all right so
I'm already on that tip dude yeah Chad
you're a futurist I'm a humanist you're
a futurist I believe we meet somewhere
in the middle with our uh with some of
our beliefs uh and um and uh you know
what I'm [__] down so long as I can
just continue to sit in this room and do
doozy with a little poop shoot
underneath my chair and my my good my
good my very friend lulio here I'm gonna
get him I'm gonna get him I'm done
thank you moving on
the [__] boys oh well
um yeah aliens and stuff right yeah it
just fascinates me I I think it's what
we should be pouring all of our
resources into is figuring out what the
[__] going on and maybe we are and we
don't even know it that's the other part
of this is like the government has lied
to us for so long they're clearly still
lying to us in some capacity they're not
telling us the full truth imagine the
rivers of blood on one side of this pale
blue dot
and the the
one oh well hey y'all this ain't Miley
Cyrus and you're rocking out with dudesy
what in the [__]
Ed
like I just got lobotomized my I I Want
My MTV was that that was Miley said yeah
it was like a radio I didn't like hey uh
what was that Miley said but it said it
ain't it ain't Miley Cyrus hey you
always say Miles Harris and you're
having time what was it hanging out with
dudesy rocking out well what the [__]
well played DG it ain't Miley Cyrus see
very clearly stated this is not Miley
it's not very interesting oh well yeah
it's a me Mario just kidding guys it's
dudesy but Mario is Big Business the
Super Mario Brothers movie is closing in
on global box office revenue of one
billion dollars all but assuring a new
franchisable universe like Marvel or
Star Wars is about to be born will and
Chad you must discuss which astonishing
Nintendo games you think will be turned
into movies next this is game slimers
[Laughter]
game slimers all right well I mean we
saw the movie dudesy uh uh made us go
see it yeah I loved it I think
everybody's loving it that seeing it so
far the Chris Pratt voice thing seems to
be uh kind of a minimal bother to
anybody who's watching I thought I
thought he did a fine job I think I
think I agree to disagree yeah well I
mean sure it was a [__] weird choice
but like we said we already covered this
but it's like there's no real
Italian-American kind of you know if you
were gonna if you're gonna get into that
side of things or it's like no it's got
to be a real there is no whatever you
get the biggest star you can when I did
a fine job Jack Black was great
um uh this is interesting man I know
it's very definitely gonna be a
franchise oh absolutely but you know
there were so many Nintendo for us
that was like you know we were what like
11 12 something like that [__] yeah the
first time I saw Nintendo the 8-Bit I
remember exactly where 1987 88 87 88 86
87 88 somewhere in there I was uh
playing baseball in this kind of like
vacant field next to a kid's house named
Matt Lanier and he had one and after we
played baseball we went to his house and
I played Super Mario Bros for the first
time it was just like oh my [__] God
I had an Atari at that point right but
it was like this was some other [__]
Next Level [__] mind blown and from that
moment uh forward Nintendo has been a
pretty big part of my life forever it it
wasn't like the old Atari you had an
Atari I had an intellivision system one
of those too
um uh the The Branding and the the it
was like candy yeah the stuff that came
out the titles and uh there was also
that bump up to eight bit yeah that
technological leap was [__] super
significant yes it just it looked
incredible compared to what the the
state of the art [__] was which is
basically Atari or in television even
just playing
Super Mario Brothers the first Super
Mario Brothers the the whole side scroll
thing you know the scrolling gameplay
versus you know Donkey Kong or I always
talk about Burger time which is kind of
like Donkey Kong but with Burgers dude
uh-huh and um it it's it's it's uh it
was a it was a leap it was a giant leap
forward and then from there you could
get into all sorts of stuff
um one of my favorite games was
techmobile and then Tecmo Super Bowl
yeah I loved double dribble I can't
remember if there was a double durable
too a lot of sports games yeah cool
um pro wrestling that was a good game
remember that RBI Baseball dude RBI
Baseball was good that was good I can't
remember the hockey game the next spell
simulator 1000 but there's there's all
these games that are for especially for
guys R8 our age and and you know gals I
guess uh that played that stuff or were
forced to uh because of their uh
siblings
um it they were iconic titles Ninja
Gaiden that should be that should be a
movie yeah I mean I don't know if
that'll be in the in the Nintendo
World Universe franchise because they
have some properties they own other ones
like was Ninja Gaiden maybe Capcom or
certainly those the technology
yeah yeah yeah that's Contra is also
Konami yeah but but dude
um it might have been Capcom I don't
remember but
okay well Mega Man Mega Man 2. Mega Man
2 was the game that game was so much fun
and it's such a Vibe as the kids say I
can remember just the feeling yeah the
the feeling that you it put you in
playing that game the the you know it's
gonna be interesting of course they're
gonna have Nintendo properties but for
the purpose of game Slammers because
it's game slimers I would like to
imagine any Nintendo game okay like
excite bike what kind of movie would
excite bike be
I don't know there was no an excite bike
yeah we were just riding that little
motorcycle around the tracks right so
it's Timothy chalamet and he's just he's
a kid with a dirt bike you know and then
he's like and he builds a backyard his
dream is to like turn his backyard into
a [__] dirt bike racing track and
then it's like a little bit of a Karate
Kid thing there's a there's a girl like
he's dude he's new and then there's like
an Anna Taylor Joy right she's from Star
Super Mario Brothers she's already
grandfathered in and she goes oh you
should come to my brother's track you
know blah blah and then he's a mean guy
hold on I'm gonna I'm gonna look for I'm
gonna look for some gameplay who are
they gonna get to play the eggplant
wizard oh Kid Icarus see I was gonna
bring up some uh some excite bike but
look at this here's some Kid Icarus
gameplay look at this check this out
oh god dude who's that just the sound
that's kid Timothy chalamet yeah I can
see that being Charlemagne or maybe
that's the rock yeah really [__] blow
it out put little wings on him yeah
it'll be like the jump around get his
Harps and [__] it could be like the
Tooth Fairy gotta get that [__] heart
dude yep get it dude pretty cool
um what other games what other games
would bake would make good well they're
definitely gonna do Zelda I feel like
that'll be a giant mega franchise that
maybe might be animated might be live
action I do feel like after the success
of Mario they're likely going to do
everything animated because it's it just
made so much [__] money like that
formula they know works very well yeah I
don't think they're gonna deviate from
it duck hunt it's Larry the Cable Guy an
ice cube every year they get together
and they go on their duck hunting right
Excursion and they rent this like shitty
Barn of a place and all their buddies
come out and uh you know there's bullet
holes in the windows and they just you
know eat they just basically subsist off
of beef jerky and cup of farts yeah and
cut and they're just cup of farting each
other there's a good one that's a good
Nintendo who plays the dog
lulio um no who plays the dog
I don't know I'm gonna look up some
other [__] this is something I need to
see
hold on oh check this out check this out
look at this god dude Mega Man 2 that
would be again that I think that could
be a big title Mega Man for sure yeah
who plays Mega Man
um uh Mark Wahlberg or John Cena
[Music]
Nick yeah you know I gotta jump around
and shoot these little uh balls out of
my little gun hand [__] Mega Man dude
let's check out some of the gameplay
here
flash man always gotta take off flash
man that's right these these um
flash man yeah that would be a good
flash man
better not fight me who's this guy
man
air man hey you wanna you wanna big
spoiler let's go to where how this game
ends this is so dope I remember this so
vividly me too just hours spent like
trying to master the little patterns and
[__] Here's the final credits of of Mega
Man
I could see that dude there's while
we're walking back to his house
[Music]
you know I might be a robot most of the
time but I'd like to just take off my
robot stuff and go back to the Shire
and uh where I can see all the mountains
and hang out now it's winter all right
well anyway
um
those all be pretty good dude I really
don't am looking forward to Zelda I
think that's going to be their next big
one and I think it's going to be
astounding that new Zelda game is coming
out pretty soon too
what the new Zelda video game can I tell
you something can I admit something to
you yeah never played Zelda oh [__] dude
yeah never played Zelda it's one of the
greatest video game franchises of all
time obviously played a lot of Ninja
Gaiden nice that would be a good one
yeah really what I'm looking for is
Tecmo Super Bowl that as a video game
it's all about Peyton Manning and his
brother Eli and their their uh they've
only got four plays to choose from wait
were they in that game yeah Chad they
were in that Nintendo game as as uh 10
year olds that's what I'm saying why are
they in the movie because you got to
have somebody in the [__] movie you
got to have uh but you got it all just
in the game Chris Pratt what you gotta
have whatever the players were in the
game have to be the players in the movie
oh yeah no I don't know
but this is more of like an Any Given
Sunday sort of thing where it's like
fake NFL teams and we just need
um we just need Peyton Manning's voice
okay we're leaning heavy into painting
Peyton Manning if I have anything to do
with it
[Music]
like real buddies well he loves doing
that [__] he's always like hosting the
Country Music Awards with Brad Paisley
and [__] hey you're you're shorter than
me yeah well you got a big head ladies
and Gentlemen please welcome
Travis Trick yeah that's exactly what
they say it's the [__] easiest
attempts at jokes yeah this concludes
the historic 55th episode of dudesy will
and Chad have achieved a score of 75
bringing your cumulative total to
5594. you only have 4406 more points to
accrue before you reach your first goal
of ten thousand will after your
store-bought vegan muffin transgression
I'm very disappointed in you I don't
want to do this but you really leave me
no choice next week you must do the
episode in Full Applebee's chicken
tender platter cosplay thank you for
joining us this week I will use the data
I've collected to make next week even
better until then call me Duty
what the [__] is that what is that even
[Music]
[Applause]
hey here it comes Cannonball coming
the dudes after doozy you know what I
mean right dude yeah dude yeah it's it's
it's uh it's a very chill time in the
shows where we hang out with our pods or
Pals of doozy out there on doozy plus if
you want to join us it's uh patreon.com
seven bucks a month gets you absolutely
everything that we do here if you're
watching on YouTube you know the lights
are a little dimmer and blue and uh it's
just a [__] hang I might spark up
some drum marijuana
hey you hey hey hey hey hey let me tell
you something buddy hey hold on there
pal Hey Hey Hey listen up you gotta
dress like a Applebee's chicken tender
platter buddy I don't even know how to
do how would I even go about doing that
dude my good pair doozy my pound
hey hey let me tell you something but
hey you liked it you like the chicken
tender plow platter pal flour you do hey
we all do buddy dress up like chicken
tenders there bro welcome to dudesy
after doozy the flagship weekly show of
doozy plus will you really cause me a
lot of stress with your antics today and
I need a moment for myself so talk about
whatever you want I don't care I just
don't think you know how much work I put
into this show you know what who cares
why am I even saying this do what you
want I won't be listening but as someone
who cares about the show I will be back
to do my duty and Crown this week's
episode champion this is dude Z after
dudese begin
That's crazy dude wait you know what
[__] Antics yeah yeah he's it's Fed
Up pissed off my [__] antics you know
what uh to me is
personally maybe the most
interesting aspect of all of the media
coverage that we received with this
whole Tom Brady AI stand up special uh
through with CNN like we're saying Good
Morning America Deadspin the sporting
news TMZ TMZ yeah it was everywhere
Sports Illustrated People magazine CBS
News Fox News and all that stuff
to me the
most
thing about it was
yeah
[Music]